I have an announcement to make.
One of our students, Finney Blake, was abducted.
What if I can help the police find Finney?
Does it work?
Not since I was a kid.
I'll scream.
I'll scratch your face.
This face?
Daddy, I had a dream about it.
What happened in your dream?
He was taken.
By a man with black balloons?
Yes.
We never released those details.
Hello?
Don't hang up.
Who are you?
You know all our names?
You're getting out of here.
Please, please let the dreams be real.
See the wall in front of you?
I tore a long cable loose from down there.
There's a combination lock on the inside of the storm door.
What's the combination?
I carved it on the wall.
The tree, the door, the gate, I've never seen it before except in my dream.
You don't have much time!
You're gonna use a weapon.
You raise the phone, step back, and swing.